In this problem, a 45- ft thick confined
aquifer has a pometric surface elevation
of 92 feet above the bottom confining
layer under non-pumping conditions. A
6-in diameter fully penetrating well
pumps at a constant rate of 40 gall per
minute. The aquifer has a hydraulic
conductivity of 160 gall per day over
feet squared.
Under steadystate conditions, the
hydraulic head in the pumping well is 84
feet and an observation well measures a
hydraulic head of 88 feet some distance
away. Assuming steady radial flow and
confined conditions, about how far away
in feet from the pumping well is the
observation well located.
Okay, so let's get to solving this
problem. So if we were to search our
reference manual for confined aquifer
since those are the keywords in this
problem,
the first thing this is going to take us
to in the environmental reference manual
is the the equation in chapter 5.
So let's write this out.
Q = 2 pi T H2 - H1
over the natural log of R2 over R1.
Now let's plug in what we know from the
problem and start to fill out our known.
So the first step, let's compute
transmissivity or T. So according to the
reference manual,
T is going to be equal to K * D
or in this case the hydraulic
conductivity K of
gallons per day over square feet
times the aquafer thickness of 45 ft.
Now in the reference manual you will
have noticed that the
units are specified as feet squared per
second but we can remain in units of
gallons per day as long as we set the
flow to the same units of gallons per
day instead of CFS after. And we can do
that next. So calculating this out right
now just gives you about 7200
GPD
over feet.
Next let's convert the pumping rate.
So Q here is going to be given as
40 gallons per minute.
But we're going to convert this to
gallons per day. So we'll multiply
60 men over 1 hour
and 24 hours in one day.
And this is going to solve out to about
57,600
gallons per day.
Next, we can figure out our head
difference.
So that will be the H2 minus H1 part of
the equation here.
It's important to select the correct H2
and H1.
So
don't accidentally select 92 here, but
rather for H2.
H2 is going to be the height of the
pometric surface above the bottom of the
aquifer at the distance farther away.
So in this case, that's going to be 88
ft.
and h1 is going to be the pometric
surface height above the bottom of the
aquifer at the pumping well.
So that's going to be 84 ft. So this is
just going to become equal to 4t.
And now we can find our pumping well
radi specifically r1 and r2. So the same
way that H1 is the closer of the two
values
to the pumping well, R1 is going to be
the radius at the pumping well. So we
have a 6- in diameter fully penetrating
well.
So,
R1 is going to be
0.5 ft or 6 in over two for the radius
to get 0.25
ft. It's very important not to
accidentally use 0.5 ft or 6 in itself.
If you calculate this out at the end of
the problem, you will find that it gives
you a vastly different answer.
and R2
is going to be
the term that we're solving for here.
And that is the distance away from the
pumping well that the observation well
is located. So now all of our known are
solved for or identified. So let's solve
for R2.
So we have 57,600
gallons per day equals 2 pi
t of
gallons per day over feet
times H2US H1
of 4T
over
the natural log of our unknown R2
over 0.25
ft.
So if we move this whole term up to here
and divide everything over here by 5760,
we can turn this to
ln
R2 over 0.25 25
equals
about 3.14.
If we then add the base E to each of
those, this will give us
R2
over 0.25
equals about 23.1.
So, R2 is going to be equal to 5.78
ft, which is our second answer over
here.
And that's your observation well
distance away from the main pumping
well.
So, these problems can be fairly
straightforward, but there are a few
pitfalls that can be easy to fall into
if you aren't paying close attention.
The first would be standardizing your
units and remembering to multiply the
hydraulic conductivity
times the thickness
to get transmissivity.
Let your units be your guide. The next
two are identifying the proper H2 term
and not picking
the other number mentioned in the
problem.
And then remembering that R1 is also
still a radius and not a diameter. If
you can keep track of all these things,
you'll be in good shape for this
problem. And that's it.